this week we got crack machines ear web
and uber escape take it away tip-top of
a for our first story there have been
these crack pipe vending machines in
Jersey least or my anew in Norway nope
crack pipe vending machines are they
used a brand new brand new I guess they
gotta be brand new but the Underground's
good that's good no they're they're just
like they're cemented in the city
property oh yeah yeah it's gotta be with
like one of those countries in the
Netherlands yeah that's like you've
called listing all that Stockholm nope
really this any place in the state of
New York that is revolutionary is it to
help the homeless get access to disease
free crack pipes the government didn't
do this
someone puppies oh yeah it's an art
installation No so these vending
machines I want to show you a video of
it says pens you could buy it for $2 but
once you open up the pen there's a
scream in there and you just take out
the ink and then they use it for crack
pipe oh no so this is all sporting a
simple design these blue vending
machines were cemented into the ground
in at least three locations in Suffolk
and claim to advertise live in KC on me
pains that would be customers a whole
lot more under need for padlocks cuz
they're all out of money and then why
the glass tube which is used as the pipe
your screen which would separate the
drugs from the pipe they would light it
and smoke the other end of it
no I'd the glass not break in there I
wish you used actual practice dentistry
any questions you know you could relax
oh yeah there you go
that's crazy offer the questions yeah a
lot of people don't know where crack
pipes come from but they come from a lot
of liquor stores where you see those
like roses
the glass thing and it's like yeah is
that right there's a lot of like tricks
that people use to sell these things
like yeah like a like a pen or whatever
yeah or you go straight up to a tobacco
shop and then don't have crack pipes
there so they don't use actual tobacco
water pipes yeah that's what y'all they
say yeah so if I if I give it to backhoe
water pipe if I use it once can I not
use the same one is there a need to get
new ones I think when the pipe gets
cracked or like it breaks cuz it's glass
they just need another one I see yeah so
they don't use the pen like an actual
pen no they don't use that and like
iPhones they have a certain amount of
time and you can use them before that I
do think there's one kid out there like
oh yeah he's got a pen there's a I've
never seen the pen one that's pretty
clever but I've seen like you know like
you'll have like a fake rose and then
it's like a glass holder yeah yeah
they'll use that yeah that's that's the
most common one and then some come with
this right it has to be glass yeah I
mean just the same with weed too has to
be glass you can't have a plastic pipe
people will smooth out of anything old
well Apple works but with not plastic or
wood good knotting Flamel I've used foil
okay yeah coil F foil works too I can
wonder like 14 or 15 I used to coke cans
apples apples good does it make it taste
good
not really I mean it's just just the
juicy part on your lips okay where
you're just trying to like suck in as
much weed hair as part of your [ __ ]
hi baby yeah okay yeah but the way that
they smoke crack out of foil is like
they usually have a piece of foil like
this and put the crack on top and then
they get like a straw and they like suck
it suck the fumes up oh that's pretty
crazy I can't believe that someone
decided to just put it there like a
newsstand what's the play right it's
like okay so you you're providing these
to get quarters right to get money it
might be drug dealers that are making
double the money so why don't they just
put a camera on whoever checks the
padlocks true yeah how do they not get
the guy yeah
just taking them down there were three
vending machines oh they're saying that
this is a crime they don't like this so
they want to take these vending machines
away I thought the cops were promoting
it what check it out there's it yeah the
way that he demonstrated that [ __ ] like
he was like like he was showing everyone
like okay that you guys are bad kids
here's why you're bad kids he thought
that that was a I thought he was really
like hey if you guys are gonna do this
[ __ ] anyways this is how you do it all
right
we've always liked that before yeah
we've heard that before so it's kind of
like having a condom vending machine
right so it's like if you're gonna [ __ ]
anyway do safe sex yeah like some places
in like Norway or whatever and where
they pass out like clean needles they
like well [ __ ] that makes sense
shoot shoot up so yeah don't get a well
then they would have legal prostitution
here already yeah cuz yeah that that
that makes sense that if there was a
clean needle vending machine then it's
like promoting you know safe usage of
syringe but when we have kids we're
gonna let them have sex in the house
because in there safely having sex in
the house it's way better that way like
we used to drink at my friend's house
and her mom was so with it because she'd
rather have us drinking somewhere safe
than like trying to hide in drive
somewhere like come drive back home
drunk or yeah that was my mom's policy
too but what if your friend overdoses in
your house or your kids friends
overdoses in yeah throw his body in the
car and the chick them to a field
somewhere and throw in the field you
mean about you know like like let's say
they're telling you they're getting
drunk but then like they're also doing
other [ __ ] when you're not looking well
I can't prevent that I don't know I'm
just saying I would over you're liable
now congratulations you're liable I
would allow you allowed it under your
house but I didn't allow it but you did
I allowed drinking underage drinking and
the eyes of those are still gonna sue
your ass
that would be trouble either way but
would you okay or not would you get with
the other parents though it'd be like is
your mom cool with this alright if your
mom's cool with it then I would prefer
that not like we're there like the
parent of what the one kid is okay and
I'm not but I'm not and yeah yeah now my
kids doing it with I'd be [ __ ] for me
too I was definitely you would call
though the parent Bill Haley so type one
wants to do doggy style you cool with
your daughter getting doggy style of my
diaper what are you talking about
doggystyle I said doggy style yeah are
you cool with that I'm sorry we had it
we had a bad luck
no that's we're talking with prop our
parents right and doing being like
having sex at home drinking at home
smoking crack at home the same
conversation we've been having you doubt
we'd be down the top top girl would you
be cool if calling the girls yeah yeah
it would have to be yeah I would be like
if I am okay with it right right and I
don't think it's fair for me to make a
decision on this child that does not
belong to as long as they do it as long
as they go by the list of approved
positions which will have posted in a
public area tagging is not cool in my
house I know what the right okay Susie's
mom is not okay with pegging so I'm
gonna go put on a strap on it but [ __ ]
the guy I think and I'm gonna tell that
girl I'm gonna die poor aside the first
time I meet her and I'm like you will
not enter my son you will not enter my
son with with a foreign object or with
your fingers you know what if he wants
it though that's not gonna happen in my
house that's so close-minded somewhere
else have to do it behind a gas station
or something like we all did in the
mirror kids won't do it now though Oh
hex behind a gas station I had less B I
had lesbian classmates and then they
would tell me that like they're so happy
that their parents are [ __ ] blind of
how lesbian they are because they'll
have sleepovers a [ __ ] long night and
I'm like oh I'm so turned off but I'm so
jealous I'm so jealous right I didn't
think of that
yep yeah because there's no couid see
over oh yeah
like no boys and they're like don't
worry mom we'll never have boys over are
you ready
it's like no it's allowed and a delight
we'll be eating each other out all night
and I'm like that's so can i watch
that's incredible
all right my next story there's the
spider inside this 60-year old man's ear
that created how big was the spider to
fit inside the ear hole I will show you
a video you can hear him moving in
that's what you went to the doctor
because he said that he was hearing like
drumming bongo drum this is crazy
[Music]
holy [ __ ] how do they get that out
what do they do on the brighter side
though you won't have any type of
cockroach crawling into your ear you had
their husband you're talking about the
doctor said that the most common things
that he pulls out of people very
cockroaches so that's what I'm saying
the good good defense yeah he had never
seen a spider web in someone's ear ever
this took place in China by their spider
lay eggs who said no web ok he's never
seen a web how does he know that he
didn't leave a wet eggs how you get that
out you use that you know that blue the
no it's like a blue squeezy squeeze and
when you put water drown the spider out
yeah with a fuzzy cool I don't know if
they you know what it creates a good
thing the blue squeezy they flush the
spider eyes you go like this and you
squeeze like babies used to get boogers
out yeah that blue squeeze you flush the
spider out
oh that was so gross he said the doctor
also said I he's seen numerous cases of
ladybirds like other flying insects
going to people do ladybirds does a
doctor I know that my bed no wait yeah
this is ladybirds but maybe they meant
ladybugs it sounded like a transgender
Turner quality into a man's [ __ ] hair
like oh they did right ladybird um but
this is a UK article do they call
ladybugs ladybirds does ladybirds class
house a [ __ ] it is baby bud oh they
call them ladybugs yeah there's a doctor
I know that they're supposed to be
professional what does a doctor see a
spider in somebody's head and go like I
would I'd be the worst doctor with the
worst bedside manners I'll be like what
the [ __ ] you know you had a spider in
there hey no you guys come in here
everybody from 12 come in here reaction
than his cuz yours is you're fascinating
and it's like interesting but his he's
like so shocked and scared like he
doesn't know what dude I like the spider
is like oh this is a nice area I put my
home here oh my god how about no one
found this area yet that's a pretty
stupid spider because it's gonna go
hungry yeah how many bugs are gonna fly
in it yeah unless that's true relax
imagine yeah the smell like to attract
spiders do they have a sense of smell
maybe that guy had so many bugs crawling
in his ear that the spider was like oh
[ __ ] him a post up here
laughs a blast story here this woman in
Las Vegas said that she oh I love Las
Vegas let's just talk about that news
story what's your story the woman in Las
Vegas she got the coupon to play the
slot machine and she used it and she won
a million dollars but then she died
because people were trying to take
selfies with her oh yeah people took her
out of the out of the water
yeah yeah that's right her well this
lady here so she called it uber she was
at a park MGM she went to clubbing with
her friends so she got into BRR
she saw that there was a car that
matched the description of the her she
walked up and she was like hey are you
here for Liz and then the guy was like
yeah get in so she got in till they
drove off to the real uber driver call
her was like hey where are you so scary
yeah so she was like holy crap him to a
movie
exactly Oh unaware is a screamin she's a
bit drunk she was going out clubbing so
maybe she was drinking but they don't
she was drinking she has no streets mom
I'm gonna show you guys a video of her
interview
look he's gonna kidnap me what you know
rape kill me anything at all shots are
going to my head and you're you freeze
and I froze the driver demand
Elizabeth's evaluating her cell phone
instead she kept the phone jump from the
car and it sped up and got away drivers
still on the loose and Elizabeth who's
angry well it was me being port made no
mention of kidnapping only robbery yeah
so she was really upset
good job isn't that kind of her fault
though so if the car is just innocently
parked there
no he drove up to her oh okay like an
uber driver I see I thought she walked
up to a car and jumped in that one might
as well be a criminal now give me all
your stuff no it doesn't work like that
that's still always the criminals fault
did he have it jumped into your he's
always a criminals fall you know what
though every time I walk up to her
they'd they say my name they'll be like
Joe and I'm like yeah she said her name
first she did I don't say that yeah I
wait till they [ __ ] recognize me and
then they tell you what you see it on
their phone aren't your toys yeah I mean
one thing I do before I get into work I
always check the like when you get a new
bird you see the face of the driver and
the type of car that they're driving
it's such a good prey check the lines a
good victim what lucky to be alive Jesus
but you don't even need to do that
there's a picture of the driver and
their car yeah yeah and the driver's
face and I look to make sure it's the
driver space but I don't I guess I just
I'm usually like playing a game on my
phone and then yeah you are cause in
Paris that all that we buried cars
looking identical they all oh yeah you
have to check the license plate on make
sure you're getting into the right one
they're black four-door sedan always
with me so I always check license plates
- you're fine yeah yeah Savannah good
thing my man is protecting me so she
suffered a head injury a fractured wrist
and a badly broken ankle how about a
head injury works it huh how about the
head injury
I don't know it just says ahead of most
worth it Hospital trip of your life oh
yeah yeah for sure yeah and then well
how fast was the car moving wasn't going
like the research well you could see in
the video I'm not sure did he pull a gun
on it no dude I don't know if I would be
that brave so she said that
yeah probably think I know this you're
not you GU peanuts what if he was an
uber driver and he [ __ ] up and picked
the wrong person up no he wasn't because
they scream yeah yeah so once she
realized that she was in the wrong car
she ended up taking a photo of him from
the side but the flash went off ha ha he
was like give me your wallet give me
your foot oh wait before that before the
photo shoots she was like trying to be
polite like hey can you just drop me off
right here and she was like no he kept
driving so he wouldn't let her out of
the car and then she took the photo and
then he said give me a wall again your
phone give me everything you have and
then she gave him the wallet she kept
her phone and she jumped out of the car
because the car was unlocked [ __ ] did he
have a gun not that if you have pepper
spray at the moment would you black yeah
yeah exactly like aren't you aren't you
like I might huh you know I put on my
seatbelt appetizer yeah I take off this
[ __ ] seat belts I bet my president
[ __ ] you know if the girls have heels
and they're suing the back you could
start attacking the [ __ ] out of his face
because you were always in his little
bottles of water I would take a bottle
of water and I would put it to his lips
so that he drowns [ __ ] isn't it way
more dangerous to to be in the front yep
been in the back so he's like how's he
gonna rob you like like this while he's
driving
yeah he doesn't have a gun and that's
why yeah because you could easily just
like oh yeah that's it yeah that's what
I would do is just maybe your wallet
give me give me your [ __ ] wallet
she said she froze but that's probably
why he picks up women cuz you know they
get scared
it seems that don't be scared then he
didn't lock the door that's like number
one exactly so he's probably done this a
million times and then it's like it's
probably easy yeah before Elizabeth
though she was really upset with the
police report because they are like the
way the police handled it or they're
just assigned to her case because they
were just asking questions about her
like why were you out so late why were
you
and then they also left out the fact
that she got kidnapped in the report she
whoa let me put that she was robbed no
was it like why are you wearing such a
short dress huh Yeah right wearing a
short dress asking for trouble
why are you wearing a shirt that says
robbed me on it - okay I I get it
because uh
this happened to my mom where she felt
interrogated by the police when she was
the victim and she was a victim of
identity theft hmm
but what ends up happening is cops have
to treat every single person as if
they're both the criminal and the victim
but they didn't really ask her a lot
about the driver right I mean I don't
know what happened in this case but then
when I when my mom was telling me that
and then like the more I guess I
researched it and I have friends who are
officers and stuff it's like you don't
know who's coming in to make a false
report so they could get something out
of it you don't know if someone's coming
in because you know they're trying to do
insurance fraud or whatever you don't
know if someone's actually a victim or
whatever so they have to walk this line
of okay is this person real or fake so
they have a set list of questions where
it doesn't really appeal to the emotions
and and seem like they care but there's
also incompetence too so it's it's a lot
of variables but wouldn't if she wanted
if the victim wanted to press charges
wouldn't they rate at these kidnapping
if that's what she wanted to put that's
something that's weird yeah that's
something that's really weird
yeah cuz that's because they should
write what the victim would've - crime
yeah what if she walked up on some fake
cops - and they're just a bunch of
people just a [ __ ] white moving van
jumps in the back of it [ __ ] strap
yourself in and then the real and then
the real cops are like oh like so you
what to do exactly pal yeah yeah you
walked up to some people and start
talking to them why did you talk to him
what were you thinking yeah with that
short skirt yeah just thought you talked
to any police officers mm-hmm
[Music]